okay I've done segments before talking
about how we might be able to solve the
gun violence problem in the United
States and I've pointed out many times
that gun violence is not going to be
solved by one thing and I've also
pointed out which by the way some of the
gun fetishists agree with me on this
that what has worked in other countries
won't necessarily work in a vacuum in
the United States and the key word there
is necessarily and the explanation for
why the United States needs unique
solutions to the gun violence problem is
that the United States has a unique
problem in our culture with guns and
I've talked about this before and it
doesn't mean that I don't want an
assault weapons ban it doesn't mean that
I don't want a ban on high-capacity
magazines it doesn't mean that I think
100% background checks are a bad idea or
that we need better connections between
our mental health system and the gun
purchasing system I think that in the
u.s. we need all of those things but
what we need to understand and this is
barely ever discussed is that we have a
unique problem in the United States with
guns that's different than in other
countries and the major problem in the
United States with guns is what I guess
we can loosely call gun fetishism right
this includes the idea of guns as
solutions to our problems this applies
to both school shooters and also to the
gun obstructionists I guess I'd call
them people who just want to get in the
way of any common-sense gun safety
regulations under the guise of oh we
need to never-never encroach upon the
Second Amendment and we need full
liberty and full freedom they use that
to justify obstructing any gun safety
regulations or laws let's talk about
background checks right background
checks alone are not going to solve that
too many Americans consider guns a way
to solve problems that can't be solved
with gun
there are examples of other countries
that have guns but they have a healthier
relationship to the guns right
Switzerland is a popular one for the
right the American pro-gun right loves
to talk about hey look Switzerland
people have guns and there's no problems
well what's different in Switzerland is
not only the laws about training
background checks and how guns have to
be stored but the relationship between
the citizens of Switzerland and their
guns is totally different than in the
United States one that I'm more
personally familiar with is Israel in
Israel you see guns everywhere because
there are soldiers everywhere young kids
doing their couple of years of mandatory
service in the military but the guns
aren't seen as cool the guns are seen as
a tool that you learn to use when you do
your service but they're not fetishized
and the gun hobby ISM it exists but it's
not fetishized the way it is in the
United States and you see this
difference in our relationship to guns
because after 9/11 airline security was
completely changed we put air marshals
on planes to try to stop hijackers and
yet we've had dozens of school shootings
and no changes mostly just bad ideas and
some good ideas that the gun fetishes
fetishist right just gets in the way of
so you can have a Second Amendment and
still not think that we should champion
people carrying guns everywhere and
putting guns in more places and movie
theaters in schools and sporting events
and bars culturally it has to be less
acceptable to be carrying around a gun
and this is a cultural change that aside
from all the other changes that I think
we should make that's a cultural change
that would drastically reduce the demand
for guns it would reduce the demand for
gun stores would still be legal to have
them it would be tougher to get guns
it'd be less appealing and interesting
guns should be scarce and expensive and
honestly it's kind of late to really
make this change in our culture easily
because we have this sort of trig
happy gun culture in the US that in a
lot of the world Pat when people hear
about how some Americans fetishize guns
it's alarming they see this and they say
what what is wrong with these Americans
that they're obsessed with their guns so
I think that yes the law can influence
the culture to some degree but the
culture is a unique problem that we have
here in the United States and it's
because America has always had a gun
culture whether it be having the right
to bear arms or exploring the new
frontier or having all this land in the
middle of the country sure a lot of
shooting and hunting goes on and it will
always go on in part because we do have
a constitutional right to bear arms
doesn't mean you can't have restrictions
on those though and we're gonna talk
about that later because that's a key
point but yes this is this is not saying
let's get rid of the second domain
amendment it's saying we need to
drastically change our relationship to
guns and think about seatbelts right
seatbelt laws were resisted heavily
early on seatbelts were seen as uncool
let the driver decide freedom Liberty
but then it became a ticket able offense
not to wear a seatbelt and then car
manufacturers added annoying dings when
you don't wear your seatbelt and people
mostly wear seatbelt laws marijuana law
does influence public perceptions so the
law around guns can help to change the
culture but there needs to be some
bigger introspection here as well
discuss this with us on our subreddit
where am I wrong tell me tell me where
I'm wrong about this and the culture and
the us around guns david pakman.com
slash read it if you've been hearing
about Bitcoin and cryptocurrency and you
want to get involved maybe by a little
but you just don't know how coin base is
for you coin base is the world's most
used way to buy sell and use Bitcoin
aetherium light coin and Bitcoin cash if
you sign up through david pakman.com
slash coin base and buy or transfer $100
worth of Bitcoin you'll get a ten dollar
bonus and so will we
so you'll be supporting the David Pakman
show sign up today at david pakman.com
slash coinbase